hello guys my name is Hoshino and
welcome to a code review of my lot of
dare game called growth or grow actually
it's kind of got two names because the
title of the window seems to be grow but
the name of the game seems to be growth
anyway the point is today we're going to
be reviewing the game that I made for
lunder 34 so if we go over here to my
github and we go all the way on to
growth here it is and there'll be a link
to this industry in the description this
is the entire source code to that game
now the thing is if you look at the
commits there are a few things that I
changed so basically when I submitted it
as you'll see I accidentally left the
camera speed at 10 instead of 3 so
basically what happens in the game is
you kind of speed up after a while
except I was kind of debugging that
speed up and making sure the text
aligned properly and it happened at the
right time so I really wanted to see
that I really wanted to be like I really
wanted the speed up to be obvious when I
was debugging it and I accidentally left
that card in when I when I did some
stuff to it now I also left some other
debug code in the actual game when I
submitted it initially and I think that
code is actually still in here but don't
worry after I updated the Wadden
decimation to not include debug code
anyway that is not the correct way to
ship a game but it's Lunden there so you
know fun stuff now let's download let's
download the zip file and I'll see you
guys in Eclipse
alright so as we open up eclipse here
this is actually a new workspace I'm
going to pop over into the workbench and
a lot of people ask me this all the time
so I'm just going to show you guys how
to do it one more time the best way to
import a project into eclipse is
actually pretty simple all you have to
do is head on over to the actual
workspace location so you can see that
here we have the growth workspace that
I've just created it's completely empty
this is the zip file that I downloaded
from github just you can see all the
code is here just copy that paste it in
into your workspace we can rename it
something like just growth make it a bit
easier and then in Eclipse just create a
new Java project typing the exact name
of that project folder hit
and that's it that's all you have to do
none of this right click import going
through this stuff just know just create
a new project but mash the name and as
you can see everything here is imported
properly so if we find the main class
which I believe is just called game and
I'll just adjust my stuff alright so as
we open up this main method let's just
try and hit run all right and as you can
see it works perfectly right out of the
right out of the gate which is the
correct way to handle this I was
actually worried about one thing that
might be wrong for you is if you go into
Java and properties and then build path
this jfx arty thing depending on which
version of the JDK you have it probably
won't actually like link correctly
because you might not have it at this
path basically you might need to go into
your your libraries under the build path
and the properties and actually edit the
path for that and change it to whatever
your wherever it actually is I didn't
actually I could have obviously put this
into the actual folder but it is I think
it's pretty big it's like 17 mega and I
didn't really want to do that so it
wouldn't have been a bad idea obviously
but I just didn't do it so you'll have
to find it yourself as the Java effects
I think it's usually in your JDK and
then just JRE lib and ext and then using
it says right here okay cool
so you'll need that that's only used for
audio so let's do a code review now I
haven't actually looked at this or
planned anything regarding this code
review whatsoever so this is just gonna
be kind of an on-the-fly type thing and
I'm just gonna go through this code and
talk about it a little bit and and what
if you guys have any questions about
anything I say or you feel I didn't
cover anything just leave a comment
below and I'll try and reply to as many
comments as I can so that this is more
of a complete kind of interactive code
review that involves you guys as well
alright so let's just start with this
let me preface this entire thing by
saying this code is horrendous I do not
recommend anyone really look through
this code without being like and with
the intention of really learning from it
there are some things here that I think
would probably not be too bad but most
of it is very very bad especially from
like the performance kind of
optimization point of view okay because
I made this game in about 10 hours it
was a very lazy Sunday
and I just really just did not care
about setting stuff up properly I just
wanted to get it done okay so that's the
idea okay so I didn't read this isn't
like this isn't III could've obviously
just cleaned up the code a little bit
and optimized it probably made it really
perform ten times faster
within a few hours the next day but I
just didn't really feel like it okay so
this code isn't isn't fantastically
optimized I know there are a lot of very
very silly things I do here but I just
didn't care I just I just wanted it to
work and it was kind of quote-unquote
good enough so here we have it okay so
let's talk about this this is the main
this is the main class called game as
you can see it extends canvas and
runnable so we get we essentially start
a game of making a new thread and then
that calls run and then we kind of
initialize the game of iron it and then
we get into the main game loop and
that's pretty much it that's how the
game starts so if you go into a niche
you can see that apart from setting up
the window we also set the music to
actually start playing and it will kind
of keep looping throughout the entire
lifespan of the actual application okay
that's all there is an initialization
load sounds isn't even in there low
sounds is actually in the game's
constructor as long with along with a
lot of different things so you know
should it be there maybe maybe not
doesn't really matter it seems to work
pretty fine we're not using anything
like OpenGL so we can kind of set this
up in a multi-threaded kind of thing
right so you can see that for example
like level loading and loading sounds
and whatnot happens on like one thread
and then we start a new thread for the a
from game so whilst they don't run
concurrently that's something that
OpenGL might have complained with
because if obviously if we make any kind
of OpenGL calls or anything like that in
this thread and then we might create the
context and this thread essentially and
then try to use it in the other thread
we would get problems so that's just
something to watch out for if you are if
you want to I don't know have a goal of
porting this into OpenGL or anything
like that or just in general so that's
the idea okay pretty simple the level
class is pretty much where everything is
we'll kind of go through these classes
one by one and we'll see what we what we
here but I want to talk a bit more about
the game loop so we've got this update
function and the only other thing that
it does is you can see is it just
updates level pretty simple right
it kind of just moves everything into
the updating four level which is where
everything kind of happens render
renders pretty simple as well there's
nothing really complicated here it's
very similar to like the game
programming series and all that kind of
pixel rendering stuff we essentially
have a an image that we whose pixels we
modify pretty much every frame and we
then just draw that image at the end and
that's pretty much all we get now
because font rendering because obviously
I didn't want to kind of create my own
font rendering system for that kind of
per pixel renderer I just wanted to use
Javas draw string function but I also
wanted to be able to access that from
anywhere so what I ended up doing is
creating a static string buffer which is
just basically just a list of these this
thing called string thing which if you
go to it it's just it's just a basic
struct with a bunch of data such as the
string that I want to draw where I want
to draw it on the screen the font I want
to use when R is fixed so fixed just
means whether or not the the screen
class and while the actual renderer
should offset that font at all so
basically if fixed was that to true it
means that it kind of should be offset
by the camera right so wherever the
camera is in the world we should offset
the position of the string based on
where that camera is so basically it's
fixed onto the actual war into the
actual game world right whereas if it
was if there's a set of false it's like
floating so basically if I set it equal
to position ten ten then it will be in
the top left corner of the game at all
times no matter where the cameras where
as if it was fixed it would be a ten ten
in world space rather than its current
rather than the screen space essentially
okay color yeah the default calls white
and whatnot but anyway you can see that
we set all these parameters up and then
we can go ahead and actually you can see
that offset happening you know if it's
fixed we draw the string right pretty
simple and you can see that we draw the
string at the very end of the frame so
once we draw the image which is the
actual pretty much everything if I bring
this up we could probably actually take
a look at this as well let's
close these things out so you can see
that if I don't draw the image which is
an issue because I get it actually
cleared stuff for us yeah this is fun I
could quickly fix this let's quickly fix
it so if we set the color to black and
then we fill a rectangle like that we'll
get rid of that you can see that well we
see at the essential string so these are
all the strings in the game without
anything else right if I lose the game
if I even can lose the game yeah then uh
yeah you can see that's kind of how the
string rendering worked compared to
everything else which would have just
looked like this essentially without
strings right so it's all pretty simple
nothing too difficult here a few people
were asking me during the livestream
what that whole string buffer situation
was and now you know okay cool so let's
move on the biggest class in the game is
probably level either that or screen
let's take a look at screen first
actually because screen is all the
rendering code the reason I wanted to
use pure Java and whatnot is because my
original plan was actually to use kind
of a per pixel renderer and there's no
way you can do that in OpenGL
of course you could draw quads that are
one by one pixel and that wouldn't be
the worst thing to do in the world
especially if you batch them together
but there's no reason to do that and you
do kind of use most of the your hardware
acceleration if you do that anyway and I
really wasn't interested in that at all
so there was no real reason for me to
use it of course in the end I did
actually end up using rectangles instead
of actual pixel stuff so yes this game
would have performed probably ten ten to
twenty probably like 50 more a hundred
times faster maybe not a hundred times
faster but like 50 times faster probably
if I actually used OpenGL and I actually
wrote a proper engine for it but anyway
that's not that's not the spirit of
blood I'm there anyway so screen class
we have the pixel reference so this is a
reference to the pixels that are
eventually get drawn onto the screen
we have the width and height of the
screen of course we have the offsets so
these are the camera offsets essentially
and then we have an ArrayList of lights
even though it's actually only one line
okay so this stuff is really boring
clear you can see it just goes through
every single pixel sets up to whatever
color we want effectively clear clearing
the screen the field rect method is
again extremely simple it always uses an
offset so it always depends on whether
cameras and then it essentially just
fills a like a rectangle with certain
colored pixels draw texture does exactly
the same is filled rectangle accepted
samples from a texture and you can see
that it also basically will not render
anything with an alpha or essentially so
the reason this is the reason this is
zero and whatnot well the reason alpha
says less than zero is because of course
integers and Java are all signed which
means that this is actually resulting in
essentially a negative number which is
why we say that it ran if this is
negative at all then we will not render
it or rather if it is right if it is
negative then we will render it okay
because that alpha essentially will make
sure that we are not sitting in zero
alpha okay
so drop curve and whatnot this is all
pretty simple good thing I commented
that a good thing I commented that app
before I shipped it but drop curve is
not the simplest thing actually but
basically what it does is you can see
that it will the whole the whole the
whole thing that happens here is this
calculate Bezier point okay or busier as
some people might say it no one says
that
anyway so we have all these floats and
essentially we calculate the first
second third and fourth term of a Bezier
curve you might want to Google is for
more information cuz I'm not gonna
explain it right here but this is
essentially just a very simple Messier
algorithm okay so we have the four
points that we define and then of course
they're kind of defined the weighting of
the line and then we will essentially
come up come out with a point okay so
once we get that point
you can see we get the pixel right over
here will essentially render it okay now
you can see that the thickness ends up
being used to render an actual rectangle
I used to just render single pixels
which is what I wanted to suffer
rendering and whatnot but now it's now
it essentially just renders rectangles
of quite a high thickness and the
thickness as you can see also depends on
what like what Y position was sitting at
so the close of the bottom the screen we
are the thicker it will be the closer to
the top of the screen we are like when
we actually draw this curve which is
this thing you can see it's thinner up
the top and thicker down the bottom all
right so what's next yes so you can see
that we check for all walls walls are
actually those rocks right I called them
walls for some reason initially you can
see that if there actually is a
collision with basically like one of the
top three kind of segments so a segment
is essentially a rectangle so because
this curve is made out of a bunch of
rectangles if we collide with like the
top three any of the top three really
kind of translates into being the head
of the of the plant then you can see
that we do game over otherwise if we
collide with any of the segments that
are not the top three then we actually
destroy the wall okay
so this is all about collision happening
inside the renderer ladies and gentlemen
inside the renderer that is how good
this code is and then finally of course
if we actually do here if the if the top
of the snake or I keep saying snake
because it kind of looks like a snake
but if the top of the plant hits any of
the side walls so you can see basically
by just comparing the exposition of it
then we will also lose the game light
pass this is some beautifully
inefficient code here okay so what we do
first of all is we get the position of
the light because it does only one light
we only support one life because I'm
always getting the first light in the
ArrayList we also set the lights y2
minus 400 even though was 450 so I mean
I could have just set it up here but you
know I didn't because laziness and
whatnot as I said this is not the best
code so we could figure out the
attenuation this is terrible algorithm
what we should
actually figured out a proper a proper
model for this lighting but again I
didn't do it it wouldn't have been
that's that difficult anyway but this
should basically have been one and then
we could have offset it essentially by
wanting by one or something again and
then actually had it being it in a in a
range but instead I just kind of kept
increasing this number until we got to
the brightness that I wanted and it's
just it's a bit of a mess but hey get
distance uses a square root which is why
this whole thing is very slow if I
didn't use a square root every single
pixel of every single frame then this
game would run significantly faster
probably three times faster so Square is
very expensive don't use them didn't
really need to use them here I could
have used something something like
Manhattan distance which I imagine would
have been close enough for what we're
doing but you also have to remember that
this is going through each pixel one by
one
this isn't running on the GPU or
anything so it's not it can't do
parallel processing at all
it's doing these one by one sequentially
and writing both reading and writing to
that memory which also isn't the fastest
operations but this whole thing is kind
of slow okay not to mention that we have
to use int here because we can't use
bytes because because Java doesn't
support that or Java doesn't support
unsigned types but anyway this is all a
bit of a like interesting way of doing
things this is again like if I turn off
the light paths over here then we'll get
like some flat lighting but you can see
the game will perform much faster so
what are we at like 750 s okay so seven
times faster that alive
all right it doesn't look as good but
hey it works seven times faster compared
to this so this is the lighting as you
can see okay so yeah again all it does
for those of you who are not aware as it
goes through every single pixel
calculates the distance between the
given pixel that is sampling and the
actual light source and then based on
the distance it figures out of
brightness for that pixel and it will
essentially then as you can see multiply
the pixels color by the brightness and
then write it back out into that pixel
so it just modifies every single pixel
on the screen based on how far away it
is from the light source okay and you
consider light source is actually off
the screen isn't negative 400 if I said
that is like something like I don't know
like 200 or something then you'll see it
on the screen and you cause here light
source is right here okay again very
bright very incorrectly modelled but you
get we get okay so there yeah we've done
that set camera as you can see the
camera class is literally I was going to
do I think I actually just forgot to
mention that this game has absolutely no
like camera clipping I was gonna say
frost and culling but this isn't really
frustrated camera but basically the idea
is that there is no kind of visibility
checking for any anything that gets
rendered I'm pretty sure I might have I
don't think I added that at all so it
has to go through pretty much every
single pixel of all of the squares that
we're trying to render such as all of
these and then be like somewhere in the
fill rectangle it'll be like ah hang on
we're not even remotely close to the
screen I'm going to continue but it's
already too late it's already gone
through this so it definitely could have
done some kind of camera clipping
situation making sure that what we're
trying to render is actually inside the
camera's view space but you know we
didn't do that that's also fun what else
is cool in this game so this is the
screen class let's talk about level and
how the game actually works so we have
the camera the camera is as you know
just essentially a vector to a vector 2i
so it got like you know two integers
and that's all that is okay
the points are the actual Bezier curve
points now you can see that tragically I
left code in here
I left all of this debug code in here
which lets you select one of the points
and then use the mouse to actually set
the position of it and the first version
of the litems air game actually did have
this code in it I removed it since then
but basically what you could do is you
could actually select a point and then
as you can see it's really not gonna
work with that but let's see if I can
you can see that I can move the curve to
wherever I want based on which point I
select and then moving the mouse button
so this was initially like a kind of if
I actually stopped a camera though
you'll see it properly this was this was
essentially like Ellie Ellie on kind of
debugging code that I used to actually
make sure that I hold nice and position
it where I wanted to be but obviously I
didn't need it in the future so if we
stop this okay so you can say that
fortunately I'll still move so let's not
make it move okay comment that out so if
I select like point I think for is this
one you can see that I can actually
unfortunately still going up though
maybe that's just a skull I hope we're
not actually moving it up we might be
who knows we do seem to be actually
which is a bit annoying because I'm
pretty sure what if we just at the
camera speed to like zero will that help
anything okay that seems to work so
unfortunately this is still kind of
below but you can kind of see how we can
control the points using the camera yeah
or using the mouse rather very dangerous
stuff so of course I managed to ship
that but the idea is that you're not
supposed to do that anyway
so that's what all this code is right
that's all the constellation context
stuff now walls basically this is just a
checking to make sure that if walls are
destroy that they get removed so that we
know wrong we
longer random walls are of course those
kind of lets you know what let me
quickly just open that up so this rock
thing is the actual wall right so we
remove them we also do the same thing to
entities as well update the entities so
the entities are really what entities do
we have I don't actually know what our
entities
I think the walls are entities yes so
the walls and the wall fragments are
entities and we'll talk a bit more about
the fragments and whatnot later okay so
we've got a left and right so of course
if the player presses those keys then we
will essentially move the the last
points 0.03 which is the fourth point
that is essentially the head of the
plant right and that's what you get to
control by using the arrow keys okay so
four points define the four kind of
Bezier curves if you again were to
research Bezier curves and whatnot you
would probably understand that more if
you don't already okay so pretty simple
every time the camera is why kind of
passes a certain point the cameras why
of course is the cameras vertical
position so of course the game is
continually kind of traveling in an
upward direction so the camera is
constantly kind of moving up or well yes
kind of down that anyway so the camera
is constantly moving up and when we
cross certain thresholds you can see
it's all negative because the camera is
actually moving down but anyway down is
upright because zero zero is the top
left corner so if we want to move the
camera that way we're actually moving
the camera like down okay because down
is off in this case anyway we display
speed up messages and when we change the
speed of the camera okay the speed up
message basically just as this grow
faster thing which you'll see every time
you you pass a certain
y-position for the camera and of course
it will actually spit up so this is how
the camera speed works so since the
camera speed is traveling the reason
this isn't a for-loop by the way the
camera speed is set to something like -
of course then I'll get set to three
four five six seven eight if you survive
that then you're just really good really
I haven't gotten only anywhere past
camera speed probably actually I
probably would have gotten up to like
five or so
forty thousand isn't that much but
anyway there is this is this is inside a
fall if instead of just doing something
like that which of course you could have
done is because we need to do this check
so the way that this works so these
rectangles are the actual rectangles
that we see on the side here okay
obviously I didn't want to happen like
an infinite list of them essentially and
we still have to render them every time
so what actually happens is that when we
kind of reach the end when one of these
reaches the bottom they kind of they
kind of move up to the top so they can
be seen again okay and that happens all
the time so there's really only like 20
or 40 or so for both sides of rectangles
they just keep you can see their white
position keeps moving the issue is that
the like the point at which is it
decides to move the bottommost rectangle
it's when the camera is why every fifty
kind of pixels that the camera moves it
moves the rectangles so you can see
there's two of them because it moves one
on the left side and one on the right
side okay and if we didn't have this if
we didn't have this for loop which went
one by one we might end up missing this
because if the cameras position is speed
happens to be three you can see that
it's not always going to be a multiple
of fifty okay
it might do something like 49 and then
the next one might be 52 meaning we miss
this okay so the easiest way to fix that
is just to make sure it's in a full loop
and then that means that we check we
kind of reach a camera's Y position
every time it increments by one okay and
that's the safest way of doing that
all right the score is based on the
camera speed so every single frame we
increase the score based on whatever
speed the camera is at so the score is
roughly equivalent to the cameras Y
position these are the points that we
set the swaying the East Sea so you can
see that how this kind of sways that is
all essentially sine waves okay based on
the time so the time is a variable that
keeps getting increased every frame and
based on what the time is we calculate a
position on the sine wave for all the
points except the head of this of the
plant right which is what we control so
that's pretty simple how that works
there's not really much to show you here
okay just a bunch of sine waves that's
why it kind of sways left and right what
what does this do
okay so obviously the head of the plant
happens to just move left or right
randomly throughout the game you can see
now it's moving right and I lost because
of that this is what figures that out
okay so all we do is we every time the
time you know it's cut it's essentially
random right but every every time the
actual time of the game crosses a
certain random point in time right it
will actually it's it's basically
essentially between a hundred frames and
and 200 frames right any time between
100 and 200 frames so every 100 to 200
frames a random force will be generated
which causes this to move either left or
right and generate will essentially just
generate a bunch of walls okay you can
see the amount of walls that it
generates is based on where the camera
is so the further up we get the harder
it yet because we generate more walls
okay and then of course we move the head
of the plant based on the force okay
so we also have States there are two
states there's state 0 and state 1 state
0 is the actual game being played state
1 is the game of a message so if the
game of a message is true and we press
both of these buttons then we end up
restarting the game
okay that's pretty simple so game don't
restart what does that do how do we
restart a game the way we start a game
is we just simply recreate the level
okay it's very very simple a lot of
people always ask me how to it seems to
be a very simple solution to a very
complex sounding question where people
always seem to have the problem of how
do I restart my game again and what a
lot of people will unfortunately do is
something like private void reset right
and then that will go through like every
variable set it back to zero or set it
back to its initial value and then when
you had more variables you have to reset
everything and my clear old lists it
might run help and like generate again
or something and it's just so messy the
best way to do it is simply just to
recreate the instance of your level
class and that is it okay that is pretty
much the equivalent to restarting the
actual application okay so very simple
solution to a very simple problem okay
so this whole tutorial thing by the way
is basically a list of strings or string
things which are the tutorial that you
actually see so when this is scrolling
up you see all this text scrolling down
right and all this does is as you can
see places certain texts to certain
locations okay create message will
simply kind of create this string thing
with a bunch of kind of default that we
use for this help tutorial type of type
deal and then we of course by adding it
to the tutorial what that will do is it
will actually add it to speed up message
also uses that but the way that the
tutorial is used is over here as you can
see every frame in render we actually
added into the string buffer okay again
do we need to add it into the string
buffer when we have like past the
tutorial area Nord but it still doesn't
because you know unoptimized okay I'm
actually surprised it runs this fast if
Yanis there is some serious seriously
bad kardea
okay so let's talk about Randa and first
I'm going to sneeze all right Randa so
if the state if we if the state is the
game so for playing the game then of
course we set the camera which just kind
of sets up the X offset and y offset
variables and screen would fill all the
walls or all of the actual like
rectangles we see on the sides we render
all of the walls and you know we've
render all the entities and we draw the
curve and we draw the strings and we
rather add the strings into the string
buffer so we kind of deferred the
drawing of them we can draw them
straight away because we can't and then
we this is also the score stringer we
recreate every frame um and we add that
okay and the score string as you can see
is literally just the score which gets
incremented based on how fast the camera
is going every every update okay so if
it said is 1 which means we're at the
game over we just set up a bunch of
strings again these could have been
created at the beginning and then simply
used instead of recreating themselves
every frame but you know laziness
so yeah this essentially just says
everything that you see over here on
this screen I quite like the colors as
well just having like a little bit of
like red in it and then kind of going
water green down the bottom and you can
see that is the case with these kind of
colors you can see that they
progressively have more less and less
red all right so destroy wall this gets
called from screen I believe so if we
quickly just with a shortcut for this
again is it that yeah so you can see
screen calls it over here and when we
draw the curve if we hit the wall then
we destroy the wall and that kind of
just says that if first of all the state
is game over then we don't do anything
or if the walls already destroyed we
don't do anything the reason is that
since the reason we have to do this
check is because this is actually inside
a loop and you can see that that loop is
is this like going through every single
wall and we might have hit us with since
we kind of do this since one of the
three segments at the very top can hit
it we might end up calling this just for
a wall thing three times so I could have
probably just broken away from this for
loop if we did actually hit something
like this but I didn't so
I'm sorry rather this is not the head
hitting it this is the body hitting it
so if any of the body pieces hit it
which usually is more than one piece
then it will actually keep destroying
the wall but it's already destroyed and
we can get issues with that such as the
sound playing more than once and the
score increasing one once and all that
stuff so that's why it's easier just to
return it straight away if it's already
been destroyed and of course we end up
adding a lot of broken walls if that
also gets called multiple times okay
broken walls we'll talk about in a
minute as well and wall the world or
destroy simply says destroy it's true
meaning we can delete it later okay
game over plays the sound says that one
that gets called whenever the head hits
it as you can see over here in screen
level dog game over and also if we hit
the sides which you know also happens in
screen because why not okay that's an
overview of the level class the rest is
actually really simple we've got stuff
like texture loading which is again very
simple we simply just load a an image
and extract all the pixels and put them
into this buffer this write a
spreadsheet again just goes through and
extracts certain regions of a texture
into their own texture like versions
texture class the sound uses Java
effects right the reason we use that is
because that's probable it's probably
the easiest way to play like mp3 files
and compressed sounds not like WAV files
in in Java right it's very simple as
well light just contains stuff that like
intensity that isn't even used anywhere
input again pretty simple stuff
and so like we've got really bad stuff
here like this his key type thing which
can only be called once the frame or
rather once before it's released and
yeah that's really cool stuff and GT is
the best class for like broken walls
actually so broken wall is probably one
of the other big things in here
and I'll go through animated sprite
quickly first animated sprite simply has
a texture simply has an array of
textures which make up every single
frame and then it's also got a current
texture which is the kind of frame and
well all that happens is when you in it
when you instantiate it you give it up
much for textures and then every time
update is called you basically increase
the counter and then you of course loop
the counter
when it reaches the end of the animation
and you set the card I should do
whatever the whatever framework to okay
and then you can of course get that
current texture and that is it very very
simple so we simply we simply increment
the index of the texture that we're up
to based on what frame were we're we're
up to in the animated sprite and and
that is it really simple stuff okay
broken wall the last thing I'm going to
cover which is yeah and of everything so
this is quite interesting we load a
spreadsheet we created an animated
sprite based on we created an animated
sprite array based on this sprite sheet
let's take a look at the sprite sheet so
broken wall of course is what happens
when you actually let me see if I can
reach it here so you can actually see
what what I'm talking about
I'm considering just want to find the
code to make it appear faster but am I
going to okay so I had to skip until we
found it that we found like a cool thing
so you can see that when I hit it it
kind of explodes and a bunch of
fragments kind of fly up just like that
okay so that's what broken wall is
broken wall is responsible for each of
those pieces so what happens is the
original wall which is this thing this
rock this disappears and then what we
get left with is this kind of huge
spreadsheet which contains each of the
different pieces of the actual original
kind of rock which is which is this
thing right this is the original rock
and then we split that up into a bunch
of pieces so these are all the different
paces and then all that these kind of
frames are so the vertical kind of
coordinate decides which of these pieces
because this has cut into a bunch of
pieces and then the if we go through the
horizontal right this is just simply
this piece rotated in two different
rotations randomly pretty much okay so
you can see that it's just rotated and
that's just so we don't have to do any
kind of rotation in Java in like a
perfect little type of deal because
that's not going to be fast or look good
so that's all it is so it loads that
spritesheet we've got a bunch of offsets
that it sets up these are purely
hard-coded offsets so that we can put
this back together okay so we basically
we look at each of these fragments which
aren't randomly rotated they're actually
in the correct orientation to make this
up and then we put the puzzle which is
all this back together that's what these
offsets are and then we we can see that
we've got this this little this little
animation class which is just
essentially a list of positions so this
is like a basically a bunch of keyframes
right so we create a bunch of key frames
we keyframe the position of the of every
fragment and then of course there are 12
actual fragments so we we we create that
and we create twelve animations one for
each fragment and then this is the
actual animation being created all we do
is we go through 24 frames the first
frame is just
the initial initial position and then
what we do is we kind of we modify the
position by adding the offset which
happens to also be the direction in
which travel in along with a little bit
of gravity and then we just add that
into D into the animation and that's it
so it's really simple we just kind of
create 24 frames of just different
positions which kind of go in and
explody kind of pattern and that's it
and then of course in the update it
loops for every single sprite updated
which updates the animation plays the
frame and retrieves the correct position
and what an odd is you can see over here
so when we when we come to render the MS
at the animated sprites we look up the
position based on what the current
keyframe is and what the current frame
is that we can look at the keyframe
which is what the frame thing is which
gets incremented of course every three
every three game frame so 20 times per
second and then we draw the texture so
that's it really simple nothing too
fancy but it gets the job done and it
looks pretty cool so anyway that is it
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
have any more questions about things
that I Pappas didn't cover leave a
comment below honestly this wasn't a
very complicated or difficult game or
anything like that
there wasn't anything really too crazy
going on again I did it I did it I did
it in like you know just one day pretty
much and I didn't really really spend
too much time on it couldn't really be
bothered to be honest but I really liked
what what I came up with I had a very
busy weekend which is why I couldn't
devote as much time to let him do this
time as I would have liked to but I was
pretty happy with the game that that I
ended up coming up with and yeah it's
quite nice might make a mobile version
of this game but um anyway thanks
watching guys and I'll see you next time
goodbye